so this session is about graphical react
Redux Apolo and our beloved Rupa
so to shortly introduce us my name is
Michael or people call vision it so I'm
the CTO of Amit labs and with me we have
Brandon one of our developers from
amazing labs Austin amis labs does a lot
of different things and one of them is
Drupal and recently we also do quite
some react but actually if we look a bit
at the past between 2013 when the whole
idea of decoupled came up we were
actually a big big opponent of it why
there were a lot of different reasons
and our lead developer in Zurich
Sebastian or also called foobie he
actually wrote a blog post which you can
see yes ok
so he wrote a blog post about headless
Drupal the cake is a lie
and so how he comes we never really
implemented any decoupled sites because
we saw a lot of issues if you want to
read his blog post search for and had
this reporter cake is lie basically it's
about accessibility performance
overheads that decoupled websites create
so in October 2016 we had a client in
the middle of Zurich team that asked us
we would like to build 12 websites that
look completely different from the front
end but they want to use all the same
back end plus they're gonna be most
probably 12 different teams that
implement the different front ends but
again they still want to use the same
Drupal back-end so initially you think
about okay well hmm and then you maybe
go into a face of like what like why and
like what the hell how could we even do
that and yeah then we started thinking
like it has to be possible but we really
thought like we don't just want to
create 12 different themes for the same
Drupal site because if we looked at the
sides they were so vastly different than
some
them worked completely different so we
had an idea we had an idea to actually
go back to the thing that we didn't like
the decoupled let's look at that again
let's look what happened over the last
three years and we did that and this
morning really this morning I got up at
6 o'clock in the morning we launched our
first fully decoupled react website with
graph QL Apolo and redux that talks to a
Drupal 8 and back-end so what does it do
so we have a Drupal on the back end we
have react
Apolo and redux front-end what all of
them do we will go a bit deeper into and
in between we have a graphical API that
allows the front-end react Apollo Redux
talk to the backend in Drupal 8 so how
do you feel today
actually pretty happy it is right now
for us the most exciting thing that's
happening because we feel it is finally
possible to do decoupled websites in a
good way and I gonna show you together
with friends and today how we do that
what are the different components how do
they work
and yes they're gonna be quite some
demos involved and we really hope that
the demo god is nice to us today that it
works so the presentation is going to be
about graphical what is it graph QL in
Drupal then we're going to talk about
react as a front-end and then we want to
see all together working and we're gonna
do that but let's first go into
graphical what is graphically so graph
girl has been introduced by Facebook and
they are actually using it in all your
mobile apps they're running with draft
well since 2012 and they publicly
published the schema the idea that the
specification behind it in 2015
and since then it has been very fastly
used by a lot of different people
so let's look at that who have you has
seen the Star Wars API okay so if you
look at the Star Wars API um you have an
endpoint like here we have people 1 and
we get back we get Luke Skywalker and we
get whatever and the colors and we get
the film's but then we realize like it
now if I want to see the film's I have
to do another request and maybe in there
there are all the directors and I want
to have the birth date of the directors
so let's say I want to show something
which shows all the people plus their
films with regular rest what that is we
will end up in running a lot of
different requests or I could go to the
person that actually implemented me that
back or that API endpoint and ask him
can you instead of like showing the URL
or the the next endpoint can you just
please and inject also the director's
name but then maybe Brandon wants to do
something different and so you end up in
a lot of different api's so graph QL
fixes that graph QL comes per default
with a really nice UI that is called
graphic ul and the idea is not only that
you can write your queries in there you
can actually learn how your API works
there is no documentation that you have
to read in order to understand how to
query it so how does it work on the left
side I'm writing my query on the right
side I have the output and you're gonna
be a big fan of control space and
comment space because if I press control
space it shows me all the different
fields I can request so I can say what I
want to have a person and I want to
define the person so I just open an
bracket and say okay person ID is 1 and
I press comment enter and it gives me
already an ID back while that idea is
maybe not the cool stuff so I'm saying
hmm what can I get off that person so it
now shows me all the fields inside that
person and I can say name
and I press ENTER and that's good look
Skywalker not very fancy so for
everything we can do by a REST API but
now let's look at that
so in there I'm not only having fields
but I'm also having relationships to
other objects there is a film connection
relationship so I can add field collect
and add and now it autocompletes me like
you have to add some extras and some
notes but graphic you'll does it
automatically and I can see now if I
control space here now it shows me
everything that is possible up till
films and I can show the title or I can
say show me the director and now in here
on the right side I have the person Luke
Skywalker with their films when they the
title and the director so the idea
behind graphical is that you're not just
consuming API endpoints you are actually
telling the API what you want and how it
should be outputted if for example my my
app and expects the director to be let's
say something else
I can just add another name for that and
now I'm getting back blah inside of the
director so I can define to the endpoint
what I really want and the best is it I
can do multiple queries at the same time
so right now I'm requesting the person
and I'm pressing the film's in there but
I can just go down here and I can do
another one then I can say mmm by the
way and I would like to have all species
as well so and of these species
please show me language they're talking
so on top I still have my request but at
the bottom at the same time with one
single API request I'm also getting all
the species with all their languages so
basically the idea is you give the power
to the person that actually need
the data you're just exposing an API and
the person that uses it can define what
they need what they use how they use it
so let's go back here
so graph QL gives you exactly what you
need you can run multiple resources at
once you can query multiple things at
once regret it and what I showed you it
actually goes much further you have
fragments you can inject variables that
you can reuse there's a lot of other
things and the very interesting part is
any schema is possible so all the fields
we requested now the person that writes
the graphical API can define them
completely your own you can create
everything where you want there the next
interesting part is we can not only
request stuff we can also create stuff
we can change stuff you could usually
have full mutation support and there
were the very interesting part of it as
well
there is no version of a graph QL API
because if you're adding another field
you just add it and the person that is
going to use it with their API can just
request it and graph QL is based on a
very strongly typed M system if we
actually go here and click on the right
side on the documentation we can see all
the different queries we have and if we
go into a person we can see that's type
person and we have different types but
we also have like the regular types but
we also have a planet type so who can
tell me a CMS that is strongly typed
Drupal Drupal 8 the entity API is fully
typed you have very strong types you
know exactly what was is so graph QL
makes a lot of sense to run inside
Drupal because we already do these
things we already have relationships
between objects we call them entity
references you already have object with
fields
we see them again in graphical so we
said let's combine them let's try it and
it works so we've built or the community
build we were part of it
Drupal graphic a module that gives you
full graphical support and because I
said I won't actually see how somebody
does as I told Brandon roughly 48 hours
24 hours ago you should try it and he
did and he will show us now what he
learned over using graphical into
roughly last 24 hours
thank you so I well yeah he gave me we
haven't talked to do you need to do some
things so I'll be using it for less than
24 hours these are all the mistakes I
made
aka new tips for you guys if you are
interested in the stuff and you want to
turn around and start using graph QL and
the next hour or so this should help you
out first of all the graph QL module for
Drupal you should use composer to
install it both branches require
external PHP libraries so just use
composer save yourself some trouble the
second thing is which version should you
use there's a 2x branch and a 3x branch
if you like all of the things that are
said on the projects description page
use 2x it includes all of the default
schema that will let you get all of the
data out of Drupal and query all that
stuff but it's the old version so if you
want to experiment with graph QL with
the Drupal site that has data already
and kind of see what queries can I run
to get the data I want the 2x branch is
the best for that however if you want to
start building this for a production
site or you think this is going to go
live I would suggest using the 3x branch
it's the new stuff it's been really
tected has a much better object-oriented
style
easier to extend your own schema and
coming in May it will have full Drupal
schema support just like the 2x branch
so if you waited just just a little bit
longer you'll have everything that 2x
has it's a much better developer
experience much more maintainable so
usage basics this may seem obvious at
first but you should learn graph QL
first before you start using graph QL
Drupal if you think that you're gonna
install graph QL and that gives you
everything you need to know to start
writing queries that's not exactly
correct but the syntax is simple the
concepts are simple just go to the graph
QL that org slash learn you'll get all
the basic concepts and that will give
you all the necessary information you
need to then start using the graphical
UI which Michael showed you in the demo
the good news is this comes with both
versions of the graph QL module so if
you install graph QL module and Drupal
you will get the graphical user
interface and with your basic
understanding of queries you can use the
autocomplete that the graphical module
gives you to start Auto completing all
of your Drupal stuff and that is a much
better way to learn exactly how graph QL
module in Drupal works and what schema
it provides so I have some examples if
you use the 2x branch this is the schema
that the graph QL module provides so one
example is you can run node query type
searches so on the Left I'm saying give
me all nodes with the title test article
return the node ID the status the
rendered output and the user ID and on
the right hand side it gives me all that
information and that's just built in you
install the module you go to slash
graphical slash Explorer and you get
your data and you can start querying
that immediately for the 3 X branch it's
much less out-of-the-box friendly the
only things that are really easy to do
is you can query
entity by ID and then you can get the ID
back and that's it so if you want more
data than that from the 3x branch you do
have to actually write some code
fortunately like I said it's bringing
rear connected much better
object-oriented programming style it's
actually not that bad there's a class
for your schema there's a class for your
fields and there's a class for your
types you write a little bit of glue
code you extend all the base classes
from graph QL and all your autocomplete
stuff starts working in the graphical
and everything works well so my advice
is in the three experience for graph QL
module there is a example module it has
if you also enable that you will get a
lot more data out of your Drupal
database by default but it like replaces
everything so you wouldn't want to use
that example module in production you
would just use it as an example for
writing your own module there's also a
module in the deep Drupal decoupled app
which might a little demo a little bit
later called graph QL underscore demo it
also has a lot more code to kind of tell
you or give you an example of how you
should write your own stuff so for the
3x branch it's much nicer that you get
this kind of base schema that the
graphical mode module gives you but in
your custom module you can extend the
schema with anything you want so that
gives you you can start writing your own
custom graphical modules and stuff so I
started writing the graphical back-end
for the Texas camp website which is
built in react and we already had a
Drupal site with back-end data in it so
this is the structure it kind of looks
like you first define the root query
field which here is section by name that
will return a type which I have the
section type and on the section type you
define what fields are available and I
say
I want to return a body and image and a
title so it's really just three classes
a little schema glue and you've got data
being returned out of your graph QL API
and so in just a couple hours after
figuring out a few things which
hopefully you now don't have to also I
had a totally functioning graph QL app
in like 30 minutes I've plugged in the
Apollo stuff with reacts and I had react
querying and getting data from Drupal
and it's all up and running and I have a
fully functional Drupal graphic will and
react up it's very easy okay you might
wonder like okay it looks or it sounds
like not fully done yeah things while we
actually use it in production so the
sites that you might be already queried
is running that behind and and yes we
will write a default schema for it so
the idea is that when you download the
graphical module there is a schema in
there that you can enable it's going to
be opinionated by us so based on like
how the routes are called and things
like that that's based on that if you
don't like that or if you need a subset
of it you can take it and you can
disable parts of it but the idea is
really that you can install a graphical
module on the Drupal site and everything
can be requested and I'm talking about
everything we're not only talking about
config content entities we're also
talking about config entities so
everything that is within Drupal that is
somehow accessible we will out we will
be able to M do through graphical
another thing is also we have full
Drupal cash and cash tag support so
everything that you load even though you
go very deeply is using itself the
Drupal cash ring in the cash interface
with the cash tags so if you um if you
make graphical request with the Drupal
module you see a huge amount of cash
tags in there you can use them and stuff
like that and we're also already
supporting mutations so you can create
entities biographic um so basically you
can do whatever you want directly and
via craft
so let's now move from the backend and
the graphical in between let's move to
the front end as I mentioned we're using
react Apollo and Redux and so react is
probably the thing that you already know
that's the front end library again by
Facebook and that has is quite widely
used right now and plus there is Apollo
Apollo is a project of the graphical
community and the Polo basically
provides a very broad set of lie or
tools that you can use graph QL in
almost every language so there isn't
graphic there's a graph kill for react
there's a graph QL just for regular
JavaScript there is a graph PL for
Python for PHP things like that so how
do I communicate with a graph QL
endpoint there's a graphical server
implementation as well if you want to
write your own graph QL and all these
things go to the Apollo and website you
will see there and we are using the
graphical client for react that react
can actually talk to em the Drupa and
then for the people that already have
used react apollo uses redux redux is a
state container which allows you to have
different states of your react app so
you can jump back and forward and you
know exactly what happened it makes it
much easier for debugging and what
exactly happens but also and for
performance and things so if we go back
to 2013 2016 I said amis labs was a big
opponent of react or decoupled in
general and one of the big problems that
we saw was SEO and accessibility why
well if you have a decoupled app and if
you had one in the past all that was
sent to the browser was an HTML
structure with ten lines of code with
maybe one JavaScript file in there that
then loaded all the stuff and now please
show that to a crawler that cannot run
JavaScript or show that to a screen
reader that cannot show joust run
JavaScript so what happens is all these
things cannot load it so you have
problems in SEO yet huge problem with
accessible
comes in as a morphic javascript so the
idea behind isomorphic is your browser
requests the first page and that request
goes to a node.js server and that noche
server has the code that you run in the
browser also running locally so the
server pre renders everything for you
and inside the notes is so it makes like
API requests to the Drupal and stuff
like that
and then it sends everything renders the
whole HTML with all the CSS like like it
would not be a JavaScript app it sends
it to the browser the browser displays
it so that means a crawler or something
that cannot run JavaScript can display
it no problem there's no JavaScript then
there is a time little piece of Travis
script in that response in that HTML and
what happens the browser will execute
that JavaScript and talk and the
JavaScript will slowly take over the
whole site so every link gets like gets
replaced by react links and things like
that so it morphs into a full react tag
and after that every additional requests
go to the API directly you're not
talking to the node server anymore and
the react app queries graphical directly
and renders that sounds complicated it's
actually not but let's look at it so we
go to our website that we just launched
today and it's WW comeö dot CH it's
about food and it's German sorry and but
it will be translated to French and soon
and but we also will have other
languages so and if I visit the website
um the very first time and actually let
me disable JavaScript because that's the
best so I'm disabling javascript in my
browser right now and I'm refreshing the
page and you can see that the whole page
is loaded so everything is there that
you would expect from a regular website
and I can also click these things and it
will load me
another URL still with JavaScript
completely disabled so what actually
happens is on WWE comeö to th is the
node.js server running and every request
that goes in is pre-rendered and sent
back to the browser now I enable
JavaScript again and what we can
actually see if we go to the network tab
and visit the site the page is loaded
already and we do some additional
graphical requests already to make sure
that that is but we fish we go if I now
let's say click on one of the articles
and we look here in graphical it only
makes two graphical requests the first
one is actually a course check because
and we have different domains so you
don't have to worry about that
but the actual request happens in here
so we have a graphical request that
tells the backend what we actually want
and in the front-end we have all the
things the whole object everything given
react gets that and will render that and
if I click now around if I go back to
the start page if I go back in there you
can see how fast it is and the reason is
graphical or the react is actually
caching all the requests so Redux and
comes into play and helps us caching all
these things so the site is super fast
after you have it done once on your and
on your site and you can see there not
even any more graphical requests anymore
so if I if I'm on the side and go back
to the start page there's no single
graphical request because the react app
already has that cache and will use it
so the first request is completely non
HTM and no JavaScript JavaScript will
render will morph into a full react app
and after that you have one if your
browser does not support JavaScript it's
never executed and the whole behavior is
still the same so the site can be
crawled
it's accessibility wise it can be read
by screen readers and stuff like that so
that was for us the first step that we
really said ok now it gets interesting
now we feel we can do decoupled apps
because
problems of SEO and accessibility are
addressed the next problem though that a
lot of people said and quite frankly
correct was performance if you use a
regular REST API to load stuff you will
have a lot of different requests to the
backend if we look at that site we have
a menu with a with a flyout menu with a
half a header we have multiple articles
we have a footer down here we have
inject so usually these things are all
separate endpoints and you would request
them one by one
via rest so we couldn't end up in having
10 with 10 to 15 different requests
which takes very long as we learnt
though with graph QL we can do multiple
requests in a single one so react
appalled and redux together keep an
internal cache of everything that
already has been loaded and because
graph QL can do can request multiple
resources in one single request together
they will figure out what do I still
need and what do I not need so let's
look at that so we see here on the
website we have a photo here and the
footer M is actually injected by Drupal
so the the react has no idea what
exactly is in that footer in there and
we have another site that or another
page that has a map so the map allows
you to like filter you can sorry the map
and you can filter for it you can you
can scroll through it one of the things
we will see if my site loads the map
does not have a footer so right now I'm
visiting the whole site without never
loading the footer and because there is
none like that design decides there is
no photo bear so if we now look at the
inspector and see the network type and
we filter for graph QL again now I go to
the store page the store page has a
footer so what happens and the store
page obviously has also a lot of code
about the store page itself so react
will
nice that the footer is missing and will
also load the footer it will not though
create the separate request for the
footer it will request two resources at
once
once the soar page end to put it
together so I click here and you can see
graphical loaded things and now we see
in here we actually have within one
graphical request we have two replies
one of them is the store page the other
one is to footer here so we see the
footer primary menu we see all the links
in there and where do they link things
like that all things given by Drupal and
now let's say I'm visiting one of these
articles and now the folder is already
loaded so I click on that and I can see
the graphical responds for that one does
not have to footer any more in there
it's just some social feed stuff so that
gives me the opportunity to really only
load the things that I really need and
if I need a lot of stuff I can put all
of them in one thing of a request sent
them over Drupal can generate all that
stuff and send it back and you have only
one single request that really happens
so that was for us that really took the
decision that we said okay we want to
try it or we want to go forward we want
to use it because then major to things I
see on accessibility plus performance
were fixed for us interestingly after we
started to implement and do some stuff
we realized hey we need to run now it is
now and so you'd not only like put some
JavaScript files on Drupal and let
Travis and like triple output that you
actually need a note server running and
in your hosting environment so how do we
do that like that so the top part
the top part is Drupal it's as I said
there are multiple drupal there are
multiple front ends and there's one
single Drupal site in there the Drupal
itself and there is a graph QL Drupal
module in there so that's one and that's
going to be the same at the bottom these
orange things that each of the sides as
I mentioned they are completely separate
so they are completely separate react
apps that all talk by the same graphical
API to the same Drupal and of course
they share some libraries and we we do
some by NPM or yarn where we share
libraries that we've built but at the
end they're all separate so what happens
is the browser at the front will make a
single request to the node and as we
learned before there and the node has to
render that because the browser never
visited the site so the browser makes a
request and ends up on our doctor
hosting stack so the node chess is all
hosted in docker and in there there is a
No Trace Express server with the react
everything running so that's the
isomorphic part and what that thing will
do it will actually make a graph cure
request to the Drupal so that's the pre
rendering part and after that is
pre-rendered it sent back to the browser
you can see in there we have multiple
Citians and all these requests they're
all cached so um if the actuals of store
page is cached is also cashed in in a
CDN so if somebody already visited that
you're not even landing here you go
directly to the CDN and it sends you the
whole page back already cached and then
the isomorphic happens am we are also
caching the graphical requests because
the graphical requests are very similar
they have one URL and a lot of data in
them so we cache them as well there's a
CDN in there as well that cache is a and
now the fun part comes if the browser
can execute JavaScript and does
isomorphic things and isomorphous itself
in a full react em it actually makes now
graph QL requests directly to the drupal
the node part is completely ignored from
that point on because it's not necessary
more it runs in your browser now and but
it goes still through the same CDN
requests that take that there that the
node itself
go through now you might say well that's
a lot of CTN yes it is and actually very
interesting part is we have multiple
cache layers in there so we're using
cache tags to invalidate and so the
drupal here sends cache tags back
through graphical requests and the node
itself will take these cache tags add
some more to them and send it back to
the browser so the city and that is in
between will also catch them and if now
like a node changes Drupal actually
connects to all these idioms and tells
them hey please remove that cache tag
and remove that cache tag and at the
same time all of the requests are fully
invalidated and the next person that
goes in will request it the images
itself they're completely bypassed by
node and they're generated by Drupal
they're cached as well no big deal there
and and if we now actually have multiple
sites so let's say that is a Heroku Mia
and we will launch 11 orders and we will
just create just the front-end will be
replicated and so the front thing can
look completely different and then we
actually do um the same fun here as well
if you are more questions about that and
if you want to actually see I could talk
to hours about that come and see me
later and I can show you how exactly it
works and but with that we have a really
fast website that is completely cached
and allows us to run node and Drupal in
parallel and without needing to worry
like I'm clearing too much things and
stuff like that okay so now we only
talked about graph QL and we talked
about direct and Apollo and Redux me
talked about Rupa wouldn't be cool to
actually see everything running together
so everything you need you will find on
that github URL I will tweet it later on
and foobie he is the guy that actually
wrote a blog post that the cake is a lie
and he is one of our lead developers and
he and and published that whole app and
if you actually want to look at that
thingy and let's go there so it is a
full Drupal with graphical in there and
it's also a full react and redux in the
poll
app so we see here there is a back end
in the front end and inside the front
end we actually have in package Jason
you can see that we are loading react
react Apollo your ordinary Docs and all
these things and there is a readme that
explains you what to do you clone it
you run composer install your run yarn
install or if you see one use NPM that
also works and then the whole thing is
actually hosted on the Maisie I your
local development environment so you
start the doctor containers you install
the site and you enable the graphical
module and that here is the graphical
demo module that Brandon before talked
about that does some of the things that
are currently missing in the graph
killed so if you want to see how that
works go in there and then we run our
front-end so let's do that I've already
done it and so we're a bit faster here
so that is my decoupled backend running
on the messiyah a doctor environment and
and in here I created an article that is
called hello DrupalCon we can see it's
note 1 and in there I've written hello
in there and you can see that's a
regular Drupal there's nothing else
that's just M the whole thing and now if
I opened the front-end so the front end
is running inside a node.js Express
server and that is listening to port
3000 I started that with am just yarn
start and so that automatically puts
everything and if I now go to that URL
local L 3000 note slash 1 so the react
will actually see that the URL is a path
that tells me which node should be
loaded and if I go here I can see it
tells me hello DrupalCon it gives me
back hello and if we actually look at
the code here we can see there is no
server-side rendering enabled right now
so it is completely and that's the 10
lines of code I talked before about and
so it just sends you back to react the
whole react is booted the react actually
then queries through po we're using
Apollo Apollo has an awesome Chrome
extension that you can see the actual
queries
so I can click on there and I can see
that it requests Drupal with a variable
note / 1 and here is the whole query
string so this already does some
fragments and it's a bit extended things
and of graphical what is possible but
you can see that all these requests and
there is actually also a graphic world
inside of that thing so I can click here
and I can see the request that happens
to the graphical of troop well and also
the return and that is just rendered
inside react and regular react
components and nothing special there and
if I now let's say add another content
hello react and I publish that I go back
to my notes - and I have that as well
and because it's fun and because we
usually like to have note overviews
there is also an overview here if i
refresh that here I can see there's an
article overview that renders me the
article I can click on it if we want to
look at that query here we can see that
an article overview query and it does
also graphical so you can take that
thing download it and start it and you
can play around you can learn react in
it you can gonna follow in it you can
learn Drupal I think you can learn and
craft curl in it it really should be
here for anybody that is interested in
using it to get a very fast start so
overall if we look back of what we have
done in the last six months it was a
very high initial investment and to be
honest there were also multiple doubts
in bit while we were on it if it was the
right decision because we had to build a
graphical module we had to we had to
learn everything about react we had to
do a lot of different things but we are
as a company were committed to open
source everything that we've done for
that so you will find things on foo peas
m and get up you will find em
on ours we will buy Rock post about it
we're gonna continue our talk about we
really believe that is one possible
future how in the future Drupal can work
with decoupled we don't say that every
Drupal site needs to be decoupled but
there are some cases where it makes a
lot of sense and right now it's very
complicated to do that because you have
to learn a lot of things that's why we
have like these decoupled and starting
and packages for you to start and play
around with it and the developers are
obviously very happy because they can
now use the coupled front ends the
client is very happy because he's not
gonna pay a lot of money for just a lot
of different tuple sites if they we just
have to implement the front end and
overall I feel we're very excited about
the future so that's it
[Applause]